she tackled the other lady and she met
her and we had to call security
I worked every Black Friday ever and so
one year working at the store and a
woman and her husband came into the
store a silly the husband really has to
go to the bathroom we don't allow retail
shoppers to use our bathroom because
it's in the stockroom and it makes it
really easy to steal things so we just
basically directed him to the food court
we're like the food court is that way if
you like to use that bathroom you can
but we can't allow you to use that
bathroom they were furious at us that we
wouldn't let them use the bathroom they
walked out the store and paralyzed man
he couldn't handle it for something
because he literally pissed himself
right outside our stores so the lady
ended up coming back in and she cuts
this out so Black Friday you have to be
security officers you have to be
babysitters basically you have to run
that store like it's your baby so we had
issues with customers coming in stealing
merchandise but our managers would
always tell us you know you're not
allowed to go and confront the guests
the customers you can't ask them did you
just steal that see how that cool and so
what my manager would tell us is you
would have to go up to them say
somebody's stealing I don't know a dream
angels bra so you would go up to them
and say hey ma'am I see you really like
that Jim angels push-up could I interest
you in some matching panties and
normally the customers would be like oh
crap she just saw me still they put the
items back and walk away where I lived
maybe like sure and they would take the
panties and stuff that in their bag -
thank you for helping them still and
walk out the door yeah that pretty much
happened especially on Black Friday okay
so I used to work at a very predominant
lingerie store that would give out tote
bags for Black Friday and inside the
tote bags were like little trinkets like
a lip gloss or a purview or something so
people go like totally bananas for these
tote bags so one Black Friday we open
the store at midnight and we were out of
those tote bags I think within two hours
people were so angry like so mad that we
called corporate and we're like what do
we do and they said shut the store down
so I was in charge of closing the gate
which was not fun I literally had to
like push women out of the way and be
like we're closing the gate like our
stores closing we're out of tote bags
people were banging on the gate women
were like fighting with other women for
these tote bags it was so I was
traumatized it had to be in the hundreds
like our store was massive you're one of
the largest stores in the area and I
mean they were like like they're like
banging and we had to like put a note
that's that like corporate made a
shutdown will open back at our normal
time and then I just wanted to tell
everyone I was like go home and eat some
turkey and chill out because this is
nuts
Black Friday is a time where a lot of
college students tend to go to the mall
we have a lot of party lights in our
store so when you have party lights
college students are going to show up
and try to grab as many deals as they
can cuz they're trying to have fun
during the semesters we had one party
light set in particular that people I
don't know why they wanted this it was
really cheap looking in the first place
basically what happened was there was a
middle-aged mom who was trying to get it
probably for their daughter probably for
them I don't know they grabbed the
speaker system at the same time as one
of the college girls and they decided
that it'd be real cute in the middle
Black Friday to start playing tug of war
with each other
there's no age mom had a baby I don't
know if I mentioned that but she had a
whole baby in her little carriage over
here they started fighting um she
started throwing shirts at her and that
baby was crying to the point where the
college girl I don't know who raised her
but she tackled the other lady and she
yeah
we had to call security I'm Black Friday
is a traumatizing time for employees who
work in retail and shop on Cyber Monday
just do that
stop going to Black Friday please um
them people don't want to be there
you really shouldn't want to be there I
know you want to go because it's like a
zoo don't just go whoo-ha crazy we're
spending just because you know you see a
price tag that's a little bit slashed
[Music]